two tests are used to screen for
cervical cancer the Pap test and the HPV
test your cervix is the lower part of
the uterus
at the top of your vagina
a Pap test is used to check your cervix
for abnormal cells abnormal cells can
sometimes turn into cervical cancer if
they aren't treated
in some cases your cells may also be
tested for infection from a virus called
the human papilloma virus or HPV HPV
causes most cervical cancer as well as
genital warts
the collection of cells for both tests
can be done during a pelvic exam first
your health care provider will place an
instrument called a speculum into your
vagina the speculum will be opened so
that your cervix can be seen next your
practitioner will use a scraper or brush
to gently collect cells from your cervix
your cells will be examined under a
microscope at a lab to see if any of
them are abnormal
the lab may also test your cells to see
if they show signs of HPV infection
it usually takes about one to three
weeks to get your test results
if you have questions about these tests
or your test results talk to your
provider